ich gebe den grünen kommunisten an den
klima fanatikern in anderen fraktionen
ungern recht aber ja sie haben recht
wenn sie behaupten es sei fünf vor zwölf
sie haben recht wenn sie sagen dies sei
die letzte legislatur in der die weichen
für eine bessere zukunft deutschlands
und die menschen gestellt werden können
ihnen geht es ja nicht um deutschland
sie können ja mit deutschland nichts
anfangen sie wollen die welt retten und
wenn in deutschland dafür auf der
strecke bleibt scheint es ihnen recht zu
sein und ja es ist fünf vor zwölf aber
nicht wegen eines vorrangig
menschengemachten klimawandels oder der
bekämpfung des selben ist ist fünf vor
zwölf fast schon punkt 12 weil sie mit
ihrer katastrophalen
energiepolitik wissentlich und
offensichtlich willentlich deutschland
in den abgrund steuern es ist die letzte
legislatur die mit einer allerdings
gewaltigen kraftanstrengung auch noch
verhindern könnte das völlig intakte
höchst sichere und zuverlässige kern und
kohlekraftwerke abgeschaltet werden es
ist die letzte legislatur welche die mit
sicherheit eintretenden braun und black
ops noch verhindern könnte die
unweigerlich eintreten werden wenn der
kohleausstieg samt der rein
ideologischen energie wenn er nicht
rückgängig gemacht wird mit wonne black
ops die unsere bevölkerung auf schwerste
treffen werden und deren folgen
überhaupt nicht absehbar sind nur so
viel wissen wir und das wissen auch sie
sicher sie werden verheerend sein
verheerend für die menschen verheerend
für den wirtschaftsstandort deutschland
und verheerend für unsere gesellschaft
wir wissen ist weil wir uns unserer
gesunden menschenverstand bewahrt haben
sie müssten es wissen da es in der
bundestagsdrucksache 17 strich 567 2
nieder geschrieben steht tausende tote
milliarden euro schäden eine
vollständige die stabilisierung unserer
gesellschaft bis zum ende des jahres
sind es nur noch sechs wochen bis dahin
werden drei kernkraftwerke mit knapp
4500 megawatt leistung abgeschaltet bis
ende nächsten jahres werden dann die
letzten drei mit nochmals 4500 megawatt
leistung auf nimmerwiedersehen
abgeschaltet die lieferten jedes jahr
mehr
als alle solaranlagen zusammen das muss
rückgängig gemacht werden auf der stelle
und mit ihrer hilfe
werte kolleginnen und kollegen der fdp
und union könnten wir das auch tun hier
und jetzt eine mehrheit dafür wäre
vorhanden auch wenn dafür viele über
ihren schatten springen müssten tun sie
es sie sind es den menschen schuldig
folgen sie nicht weiter den kommunisten
die unter dem deckmantel das klima
retten zu wollen deutschland zugrunde
richten die kommunisten propagierten
früher sie wollten das proletariat
befreien aber das proletariat
bewährte sich irgendwann gegen diese
vereinnahmung weil es keine befreiung
sondern eine versklavung war nachdem
auch die befreiung der afrikaner nicht
so richtig funktionieren wollte dachten
sich die kommunisten einen genialen
trick aus sie machten ein sogenanntes
rebranding und suchten sicherheitswelt
historische objekt zur rettung die tiere
die pflanzen und das klima aus wohl
wissend dass diese sich nicht wehren
können inzwischen ist die 26
klimakonferenz in glasgow fast vorbei
wie die grüne helden greta treffend
bemerkte kam wieder einmal nicht viel
mehr dabei heraus als ich zitiere mit
ihrer genehmigung bla bla bla da sind
sich fast alle einig und es wurde auch
viel darüber berichtet kaum berichtet
wird dagegen darüber dass die
landwirtschaft keine dünger mehr bekommt
weil die energie auch dank der
verweigerung politik gegenüber fossile
brennstoffe zu teuer gewonnenes damit
sind die kommenden ernten gefährdet der
gaspreis als in den letzten wochen mehr
als verdoppelt der strompreis um 20 30
und mehr prozent der kraftstoffpreis um
teilweise 50 prozent gestiegen und kein
ende ist in sicht natürlich ist alles so
gewollt die grünen kommunisten wollen
dass energie zum luxus wird sie wollen
dass mobilität zum luxus wird und ihnen
ist vollkommen egal wie viele opfer es
kostet wollen sie als cdu und fdp
wirklich den wohlstand dieses landes
dieser ideologie opfern wollen sie
wirklich dass die grünen kommunisten die
zerstörung vollenden dass ihre kinder in
einem entwicklungsland aufwachsen wenn
nicht stimmen sie für unsere anträge ich
bedanke mich für eure aufmerksamkeit
kasten hälse hat hier die debatte
eröffnet zu drei anträgen der afg
fraktion zum thema energieversorgung
energiewende in deutschland
und auf ihm direkt antworten wird dem
thema und gremmels spd fraktion und in
der vergangenen legislaturperiode saß er
auch im ausschuss für wirtschaft und
energie
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren mit einer
technik von vorgestern will die ard die
herausforderungen von heute und morgen
bearbeiten das zeigt die rückwärts
gewandt sie sind meine sehr verehrten
von der art der fraktion aber da haben
wir auch nichts anderes von ihnen
erwartet und dann präsentieren sie heute
die alte mär der umweltfreundlichen
sicheren und kostengünstigen atomkraft
das war doch schon in den achtziger
jahren falsch und es ist in den 2020er
jahre recht
unfreundlich umweltfreund durch ich habe
mir die mühe gemacht kaputt nur schwer
gefallen ist den antrag mal
durchzuarbeiten umweltfreundlich also
wir müssen da nur mal an die us-truppen
und die kotierten theaterfest zu sehen
da ist es zwar nur leicht radioaktiver
müll aber das zeigt doch dass das in
keinster weise umweltfreundlich ist
gucken sie doch mal gucken sie doch mal
endlagersuche das endlager suchverfahren
läuft doch gerade zurzeit gucken sie
doch mal an stellen sie aus hessen sagen
sie möchten dass in ihrem wahlkreis
haben diese ansage habe ich von ihnen
heute nicht gehört butter bei die fische
weiter atommüll den wir produzieren für
den sind wir auch verantwortlich meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren machten
und dann auch die frage co2 neutral er
meinte den uranabbau bei der
brennelemente herstellung beim
kraftwerksbau beim kraftwerksbau bei der
endlagerung entsteht kein co2 wert es
verständlich deswegen ist auch kernkraft
nicht co2 neutral meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren und dann sagen sie man
würden uns damit unabhängiger machen ja
wo kommt denn das uran her
wo sollen wo sowohl seines uran hertha
ist gab mal in der ddr und rat bauen ja
im erzgebirge dann stehen die ich hier
hin und sagen sie möchten als afd um
unabhängig sein von energieimporten
möchten sie das uran hier in deutschland
im erzgebirge abgebaut wird auch diese
ansage habe ich heute hier nicht gehört
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
und die erfolge des uranabbaus in wismut
kostet den deutschen steuerzahler bis
heute 6,8 milliarden euro bundesmittel
dass da die schäden des abbaus
kompensiert werden meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren deswegen zeigt es auch
das ist nichts preis fertiges nicht
umweltfreundlich ist meine sehr
verehrten
man sagen sie es sicher atomkraft sei
sicher sagen wir doch mal die menschen
in tschernobyl fragen sie mal die
menschen in fukushima was die davon
halten dass das sicher sei und das macht
sie tun hat gedacht ähnliche unfälle wie
in fukushima drohen alle zehn bis 20
jahre es ist das theoretisch möglich
auch kollegin meiner sicht ein hinweis
dass es nicht sicher ist erlauben sie
eine zwischenfrage des kollegen hülse
dran
also es ist nicht sicher und wenn wir
jetzt weniger emotional mal sehen kann
man auch gucken wenn es denn sicher wäre
würden wir auf dieser welt ja einen
finden der atomkraftwerke ein
dienstleister der atomkraftwerke
versichert aber finden sie auch in der
ganzen finanzwirtschaft finden sie nicht
ein institut die atomkraft versichern
kraftwerke versichern und warum nicht
warum wenn ein schaden eintritt ist er
so stark und so immens dass das
unbezahlt und jeder versicherungskonzern
werde die füße und die knie gehen meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren und noch
etwas bei der frage der sicherheit auch
der rückbau ist eine große
herausforderung mittlerweile gibt es
atomkraft seit über 70 jahren
173 atomkraftwerke sind weltweit
mittlerweile abgeschaltet erst 19 sind
zurückgebaut auch das eine große
herausforderung und davon sicher zu
sprechen ist aus meiner sicht lachhaft
dann sagen wie kostengünstig also wir
müssen ja nur mal gucken atomkraft sei
kostengünstig gucken sie doch einfach
mal an wie viel wir in den letzten
jahren dafür bezahlt haben sie dürfen
auch nicht den strompreis als solches
als sich angucken sie müssen gucken was
da an staatlichen subvention die letzten
jahrzehnte eingezahlt worden ist und
wenn sie das dann vergleichen die
staatlichen investitionen die
subventionen und die folgekosten dann
sehen sie dass atomkraft um ein
vielfaches teurer als erneuerbar meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren da
können sie auch mal gucken nach
großbritannien hinkley point wie lange
es dauert überhaupt von der planung bis
zur fertigstellung es hätte 2017
fertiggestellt sein sollen jetzt scheint
es 2026 zu sein und die kosten zehn
milliarden euro mehr als ursprünglich
geplant eine schnelle antwort eine
kostengünstige antwort ist atomkraft
nicht meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren und die investitionen die wir
jetzt hier neue atomkraft bräuchte die
es doch viel besser aufgehoben in
erneuerbaren energien
wir wollen kein geld binden den
atomkraft dieses geld brauchen wir
investitionen in erneuerbare energien
dass wir diese schnell umsetzen können
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
ich sage ihnen für die sozialdemokratie
ist es eine freude stunde wenn am
31.12
2022 das letzte atomkraftwerk in
deutschland vom netz geht dann werden
wir die sektkorken knallen lassen meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren weil wir
das gut und wir richtig schütten und das
ein wichtiges menschheit ziel was wir
erreicht haben und ich sage ihnen sie
haben in ihrem antrag und da soll man
schlusswort teil frau präsidentin gesagt
sie würden gerne ihren horizont
erweitern
ich halte es da lieber mit udo
lindenberg hinterm horizont geht's
weiter und da kommen wir erneuerbaren
energien in diesem sinne alles gut und
glückauf
timon gremmels war das für die spd
fraktion im bundestag gibt es auch einen
parlamentarischen beirat für nachhaltige
entwicklung ist es gibt jetzt noch eine
kurzintervention von carsten hier sind
und dass die kurzintervention zu lassen
er kann mit sie haben
viel erzählt viel war dabei was den
wissenschaftlich nicht haltbar ist es
gibt kernreaktionen
kernreaktoren der generation 4 im
september ist einer dieser reaktoren ans
netz gegangen es gibt also auch jetzt
schon mehrere reaktoren in russland in
china die also hoch radioaktive
reststoffe verarbeiten das heißt die
brauchen auch kein endlager das sind
also ist also kein atommüll wie sie es
behaupten oder wie sie es sagen es sind
einfach
kernbrennstoffe kernbrennstoffe die man
verwenden kann und mit denen jetzt
gelagerten kernbrennstoffen aus unseren
jetzigen kernkraftwerken könnten wir mit
dieser technologie die natürlich
entwickelt werden muss bzw die theorie
ist eben schon man muss die bloß bauen
als test reaktoren könnten wir mit den
jetzt lager dann hoch radioaktiven
reststoffen unser land mit 150 jahre
zirka mit strom versorgen wie erklären
sie sich dass alle industriestaaten alle
industriestaaten auf der welt außer
deutschland auf kernenergie setzt alle
auch die eu will
kernenergie vorantreiben möchte die
kernenergie sozusagen jetzt sogar als
grüne energie quasi deklarieren um zu
sagen okay das ist ein weg so wie es
auch der pc sektor das am pc sagt um die
klimakatastrophe die sie am horizont
sehen zu verhindern und dann möchte ich
noch einmal auf ganz kurz auf die
erneuerbaren ganz kurz ganz kurz auf die
erneuerbaren eingehen am gestrigen tag
wurde strom produziert von diesen
sogenannten erneuerbaren und zwar 3,64
prozent der installierten leistung
3,64 prozent das heißt sind ca 110 wenn
ich richtig informiert bin kann schon
wieder ein bisschen mehr sein 110
gigawatt verbaut an installierter
leistung und geliefert haben sie circa 4
gigawatt und wir brauchen aber 70 bis 80
das wissen sie selbst herab und soll die
energie natürlich entschuldigung
herr abgeordneter grammel sie wollen
antworten
auf diese sachen muss man antworten weil
ich klagen 1 wir haben nicht die zeit zu
warten wir müssen jetzt die energiewende
einleiten wir müssen technologie die
jetzt im markt verfügbar sind die
funktionieren die in der bevölkerung
eine große akzeptanz haben und die uns
zu in die zukunft bringen die müssen wir
ausbauen wir brauchen einen
schnellstmöglichen ausbau von solar von
windkraft das sind die antworten wir
haben keine zeit auf solche märchen von
ihnen zu hören wir müssen jetzt
investieren und wir haben da eine breite
mehrheit in der bevölkerung hinter uns
und darauf bauen wir danke schön
[Applaus]
so wird also die kurzintervention ums
raf die fraktion und die reaktionen
darauf aus der spd und jetzt kann ich
noch sagen es gibt einen
parlamentarischen beirat für nachhaltige
entwicklung und in der vergangenen
legislaturperiode war mag helfrich da
mitglied cdu/csu
und kollegen vor gut zehn jahren im
frühjahr 2011 kam es zur
nuklearkatastrophe von fukushima in der
folge gab es in deutschland wieder eine
gesellschaftliche noch eine
parlamentarische mehrheit für die
fortsetzung der kernenergie der ausstieg
aus der atomkraft wurde hier im
deutschen bundestag beschlossen und wird
nächstes jahr abgeschlossen sein dann
geht das letzte deutsche kernkraftwerk
vom netz in diese form der
energieerzeugung wird in deutschland der
vergangenheit angehören
ob es der richtige weg war erst aus der
kernenergie und dann aus der kohle
auszusteigen das ist verschüttete milch
die weichen sind unumkehrbar gestellt
und das vor allem auch aus sicht der
graf werks betreiber lassen sie uns
lieber vor augen führen was wir in den
letzten zehn jahren seitdem geleistet
haben zum damaligen zeitpunkt lag der
anteil erneuerbarer energien an der
stromversorgung bei 20 prozent heute
liegen wir bei knapp 48 prozent haben
mit dem eeg solarmodule und
windkraftanlagen weltmarktfähig gemacht
und das schöne an sonne und wind ist es
gibt kein atomares erbe das wir unseren
kindern und kindeskindern in form von
atommüll hinterlassen
wir haben
zudem in der letzten legislaturperiode
den kohle ausstieg besiegelt das letzte
kohle kraftwerk soll 2038 vom netz gehen
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
damit ist deutschland weltweit das
einzige industrieland das gleichzeitig
aus kernkraft und kohle verstromung
aussteigt spd grüne und fdp haben ja
ihren regierungspapier vereinbart den
kohleausstieg idealerweise auf 2.030
vorzuziehen hierzu einige grundsätzliche
anmerkungen erstens energiewende braucht
verlässlichkeit das gilt für
ausstiegsphase genauso wie für
ausbauphase der erneuerbaren zweitens
die energiewende ist ohne
versorgungssicherheit zum scheitern
verurteilt und wenn ich
versorgungssicherheit meinen dann rede
ich von spitzenlast kraftwerken und
damit am ende natürlich auch vom gas das
sage ich in richtung der grünen der
wegfall von grundlast bei der
stromerzeugung muss kompensiert werden
und am ende bitte nicht durch den import
von tschechischen oder französischen
atomstrom
deshalb müssen wir in zukunft neben den
verstärkten ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien auch auf gas setzen und wenn
ich das sage dann meine ich zu dem
wasserstoff oder synthetisches methan
aus erneuerbaren wählen hier hat die
woche mit der nationalen wasserstoff
strategie und insbesondere dem darin
enthaltenen förderprogramm page to
global wegweisendes geleistet mit
letzterem wollen wir den globalen markt
hochlauf der produktion von grünem
wasserstoff anreizen und uns
entsprechende importmengen sichern aber
machen wir uns nichts vor als einer der
größten gast verbraucher der welt werden
wir mittelfristig auch noch auf
klassische art us importe angewiesen
sein und weil die niederländische und
britische gasförderung stark rückläufig
ist brauchen wir eine erhöhung der
kapazitäten für gasimporte aus anderen
ländern da wäre zunächst im 2 die
möglichst bald in betrieb genommen
werden sollte sie kann 55 milliarden
kubikmeter russisches erdgas und damit
40 prozent des europäischen bedarfs nach
europa transportieren herr kollege
erlauben sie eine zwischenfrage von der
afg undercover weiter ausführen wer sie
wer wie sie von den grünen die
inbetriebnahme von nord stream zwei
bekämpft besorgt am ende vor allem für
steigende energiepreise in deutschland
und europa wer versorgungssicherheit und
keine allzu hohe abhängigkeit von
russland haben will der muss vielmehr
für eine diversifizierung der
erdgasimporte sorgen sei es mittels
pipeline gast aus anderen exportländern
oder aber auch mittels energie importen
ich komme zum schluss der sich
abzeichnenden koalition möchte ich sagen
bleiben sie verlässlich und sichern sie
die eigenversorgung deutschlands mit
elektrischer energie und die importe von
erdgas grünem wasserstoff und erneuerbar
rasen der afg sage ich niemand wird der
republik den stecker ziehen und bitte
führen sie keine phantomdiskussion zu
optionen die gar nicht mehr auf dem
tisch liegen ihren antrag lehnen wir ab
oder ihre anträge dankeschön
vielen dank
ich erteile nunmehr das wort für die
fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen der
kollegin dr julia verlinken
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren liebe kolleginnen
ich empfinde es als zumutung dass sie
von der afg uns auch in dieser neuen
wahlperiode ständig mit ihren schrägen
und antiquitäten behauptungen die zeit
stehlen
atomkraft atomkraft ist gefährlich
atomkraft ist teuer und produziert am
laufenden band atommüll den für den die
nun gezwungenermaßen ein endlager finden
müssen was möglichst sicher ist und das
gibt es noch lange nicht und ich habe
sie von der afc in diesem prozess bei
der suche nach einem endlager nicht auf
der konstruktiven seite erlebt meine
damen und herren
die verheerenden unfälle von tschernobyl
und fukushima die haben gezeigt wie
riskant die atomkraft ist vor den
gefahren der atomwaffen mal ganz zu
schweigen wie er in der nutzung mit der
atomenergie verbunden sind und auch das
märchen der angeblich kostengünstiger
atomenergie das sollten sie endlich
begraben schauen sie sich doch mal die
zahlen an das ist doch längst widerlegt
neue atomkraftwerken wenn nur noch mit
erheblichen staatlichen subventionen
gebaut die private wirtschaft hat
überhaupt kein interesse daran die macht
einen weiten bogen um solche
investitionen und in wirklichkeit ist
atomkraft völlig unwirtschaftlich
[Applaus]
bei aktuellen projekten sie haben gerade
frankreich genannte explodieren die
kosten und auch die bauphasen verzögert
sich immer weiter nehmen sie zum
beispiel das atomkraftwerk flamanville
in frankreich von ursprünglich geplanten
3,3 milliarden euro baukosten sind die
kosten inzwischen auf über 19 milliarden
euro gestiegen also eine versechsfachung
das projekt ist außerdem schon zehn
jahre im verzug für diese 19 milliarden
euro könnte man locker
5000 windenergieanlagen bauen die
insgesamt das zwölffache an leistungen
haben wie der geplante reaktorblock
und teure brennstäbe brauchen sie für
die windräder auch nicht
umso fataler ist es dass die eu
kommission in der diskussion um die
kennzeichnung von nachhaltigen
investitionen von den atomstaaten dann
jetzt eingeknickt ist und atomkraft in
der sogenannten taxonomie als nachhaltig
label will das behindert das behindert
die echten zukunftsfähigen investitionen
und hält die technologie aus der
vergangenheit künstlich am leben wir
grüne halten diese entscheidung von frau
von der leyen für einen fatalen fehler
und
erhältlich unabhängigkeit von teuren
fossilen energieträgern erreichen wir
dadurch dass wir rasch mit der
energiewende voran kommen nicht dass wir
ständig neue fossile import
infrastrukturen bauen denn die
günstigste energie die stellt inzwischen
neue solar und windenergieanlagen wie
gilt es zu investieren und den fokus
drauf zu setzen es ist erstaunlich dass
sie das lachhaft finden sie sollten sich
mal besser informieren erhielt
nachdem es unter einem cdu minister
altmaier in den letzten jahren viel zu
langsam voran gegangen ist mit dem auch
kollegin
erlauben sie eine zwischenfrage außer
auf die fraktion
nachdem es unter cdu-minister heitmeier
den letzten jahren viel zu langsam voran
gegangen ist mit dem ausbau der
erneuerbaren da wollen wir nun endlich
die bremsen lösen wir wollen für einen
boom sorgen und dass das überfällig ist
sehr geehrte damen und herren dass das
überfällig ist das sagen alle aktuellen
szenarien zur energieversorgung vom bdi
über ago ag energie energiewende bis hin
zum fraunhofer projekt ariadne sind sich
alle wissenschaftler innen einig wir
brauchen viel mehr erneuerbare energie
und das so schnell wie möglich
deshalb wollen wir jetzt die hindernisse
aus dem weg räumt clan um
genehmigungsprozesse die umsetzung
massiv beschleunigen es gibt so viel
potenzial für solar- und windenergie in
deutschland wir können die dachflächen
im großen stil nutzen um mit den
richtigen hebel schaffen wir auch mehr
windenergie ans netz zu bringen auch im
süden der republik und dafür wollen wir
mit einer neuen regierungskonstellation
endlich die weichen stellen aber wir
dürfen auch die zweite seite der
energiewende nicht vergessen denn den
kampf gegen den gegen die
energieverschwendung ist ein wichtiger
auf den verkehr in der industrie gewerbe
gebäudesektor überall gibt es noch
riesiger
energieeinsparpotenziale und zeitgemäße
energieeffizienzstandards intelligente
steuerung die können wir helfen die
branche die energie-effizienz branche
die steht in den startlöchern
sie warten nur auf die richtigen
bedingungen am markt dann kann es
losgehen mit der effizienz revolution
und die wiederum hilft uns dann dabei
auch viel schneller auf 100 prozent
erneuerbare zukommen lassen sie uns
klimaschutz und energiewende als das
sehen was es ist eine riesengroße chance
für modernisierung für innovation und
vor allen dingen auch für internationale
solidarität
denn was wir hier in deutschland für
energiewende und klimaschutz tun das hat
enorme auswirkungen auf den rest der
welt die klimakrise die geht bisher vor
allem zu lasten der länder im globalen
süden die schon jetzt die auswirkungen
am heftigsten spüren sie brauchen
dringend unterstützung bei der anpassung
an die klimaveränderungen und sie
brauchen gewissheit dass die
industrienationen beim klimaschutz
vorangehen wir müssen das pariser rat
kommt deswegen endlich mit den
notwendigen maßnahmen unterfüttern meine
damen und herren aber auch bei uns sind
die dramatischen folgen der klimakrise
längst angekommen was wir diesen sommer
an der ahr und in der eifel erlebt haben
das hat alle hoffnung es werde bei uns
schon nicht so schlimm denn sie wieder
andere redezeit
allein die schäden durch dieses ereignis
hat die bundesregierung gegenüber der eu
mit 29 milliarden euro beziffert da soll
noch mal jemand sagen klimaschutz sei
teuer ich sag ihnen kein klimaschutz ist
teuer vielen dank
julia fällen war das neben- oder
abgesehen davon dass die
bundestagabgeordnete ist ist sie auch
umweltwissenschaftlerin und es gibt eine
kurzintervention aus der afg fraktion
dankeschön geehrte kolleginnen sehr
geehrte kolleginnen sie haben gesagt wir
wollen uns an die fakten halten dann
machen wir das doch einfach wir nehmen
die zahlen vom bundesministerium für
wirtschaft und energie aus der vor
kurzer zeit 2009 10 da waren die
eeg-umlage für windkraft in deutschland
für einen aufsteller zusammen bei circa
19 89 milliarden euro also schon mehr
als ein halbes kernkraftwerk der
marktwert dieses stromes aus windkraft
in 2009 10 betrug aber nur 4,1
milliarden euro seit ein
volkswirtschaftlicher verlust in diesen
tollen wunderbaren sektor von über 9
milliarden euro getragen von den
stromverbrauchern in deutschland dafür
dass der staat sie zwingt mit
überteuerten strompreisen eine nicht
wettbewerbsfähige energieerzeugungs
methode zur quer zu finanzieren als
folge davon der unzuverlässigkeit der
zeugen aus windenergie denn im schnitt
steht ein windkraftwerk drei viertel der
zeit rum ohne zu strom zu liefern hat
sich die abhängigkeit von französischen
nuklearstrom massiv erhöht der import in
2009 10 betrug 14,8 terawattstunden das
entspricht zwei kompletten
jahresproduktion von zwei französischen
kernkraftwerks blüten die in frankreich
verlaufen für den export nach
deutschland
darin hat ihre energiewende uns geführt
und es ist lächerlich wenn sie die sie
immer die ta kernkraftwerk ausstieg in
deutschland forciert haben uns in eine
abhängigkeit von weniger sicheren
anlagen im europäischen ausland treiben
mit ihrer politik
frau kollegin sie können antworten
nur zwei sachen ganz kurz zu diesen
dingen die sie gesagt haben erstens
deutschland war in den vergangenen
jahren stets netto stromexporteur
das heißt ja eine riesige über
produktion von strom die ins europäische
ausland geflossen ist und
zweitens wenn wir über kosten für
erzeugten strom sprechen dann
vergleichen sie bitte mal die quelle vom
deutschen institut für
wirtschaftsforschung oder fraunhofer ise
die sagen nämlich dass ein neues großes
kraftwerk was mit solarenergie betrieben
wird zwischen 2 und maximal sechs cent
gestehungskosten pro kilowattstunde hat
und ein atomkraftwerk zwischen 14 und 19
cent für mehr brauche ich dazu nicht zu
sagen
damit den weg zum nächsten redner in
dieser debatte zu drei anträgen der
fdp-fraktion das ist reinhard houben für
die fdp-fraktion
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
ich bin schon etwas überrascht
dass wir hier eine von der afg angeregte
so starke vergangenheits debatte führen
wem hilft das eigentlich noch wem hilft
das seitliche meine damen und herren wir
haben in den nächsten vier jahren eine
unmenge an aufgaben vor uns und dann
hilft doch nicht eine romantisierende
und zum großen teil falsche debatte über
den atomstrom wir müssen zur kenntnis
nehmen dass es weder
privatwirtschaftlich ökonomisch möglich
ist atomstrom in deutschland zu
produzieren
es ist auch politisch nicht möglich und
dann stelle ich die frage warum
beschäftigen wir uns überhaupt noch
damit ich halte das einfach für unsinnig
lassen sie uns gemeinsam darüber
nachdenken wie wir die probleme der
zukunft lösen und
natürlich ist es ein problem wenn wir
kraftwerke abstellen das wird streit die
kernbank aber
dort in eine gewisse romantik zu
verfallen hilft uns vor ort überhaupt
nicht
zweitens wir müssen auch den bürgerinnen
und bürgern vermitteln
energieerzeugung ist eigentlich in
keinem fall etwas angenehmes vor ort
niemand möchte direkt ein windkraftwerk
vor der haustür haben niemand möchte ein
kohlekraftwerk vor der haustür haben
vielleicht kann die solarenergie die
möglichkeit sein wo man sagt das können
wir mit unserem privaten leben gut
verbinden also sollten wir doch mit den
menschen mit den bürgerinnen und bürgern
darüber diskutieren ja wir brauchen
energie wir brauchen verlässliche
energie und wir brauchen auch preiswerte
energie denn wenn wir denn als
vielleicht neue ampel sagen deutschland
soll
industriestandort bleiben deutschland
soll weiterhin wirtschaftlich stark
bleiben dann müssen wir dort über
lösungen debattieren und keine debatten
über vorgestern
und
natürlich sind die herausforderungen
immens aber wir haben als öffentliche
hand natürlich schon einen einfluss
darauf wie teuer der strom ist und wir
sind ja in den debatten über die eeg
umlage durch auch schon mal ohne
geheimnisse zu warten einen gewissen
schritt weiter gekommen in den
gesprächen die wir geführt und natürlich
ist es unabdingbar
für die deutsche industrie aber
natürlich auch video deutschen
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher dass
der strompreis
günstiger werden muss
und dann haben wir uns doch zumindest in
den debatten vorgenommen wir müssen
schneller werden auch das liegt in
unserer hand wir müssen natürlich die
genehmigungsverfahren beschleunigen wir
müssen zum beispiel gibt es ja diese
interessante alternative von rwe und
basf
in der nordsee einen großen
windkraftpark zu bauen um den größten
co2 footprint in deutschland zu
neutralisieren und was sagt die
industrie
genug geld haben wir wir brauchen keine
subventionen aber gebt uns schnell
planungssicherheit damit wir diese
schwierige aufgabe lösen können und den
einstieg in das was wir gemeinsam
erreichen wollen eben schaffen und
deswegen meine damen und herren glaube
ich wir sollten nach vorne debattieren
und eine illusion sollten uns aber auch
nehmen wir werden es nicht schaffen in
deutschland so viel energie
produzieren wie wir in deutschland
benötigen vielen dank nein das wollen
wir noch nie
das konnten wir noch nie dankeschön
[Applaus]
mittlerweile hat auch das präsidium
gewechselt yvonne mag was leitet jetzt
hier die sitzung für die unionsfraktion
und ruft als nächsten auf ralph lenkert
von der linken
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin
kolleginnen und kollegen die welt auf
den kopf gestellt wie kann man heute
noch ernsthaft atomstrom fordern nach
harrisburg tschernobyl nach fukushima
und bei der ungeklärten endlagerfrage
und ehrlich ich finde es unverständlich
dass frankreich weiterhin auf atomstrom
setze ich erinnere an 2009 10 als die
französischen akw in der dürre am
verdursten worden 50 prozent ihrer
leistung verloren und wegen hitze der
stromverbrauch nach oben schneider 2009
10 haben deutsche erzeugungsanlagen
insbesondere insbesondere pv und
windkraft frankreich vor dem blackout
gerettet
wer im klimawandel auch atomstrom setzt
der lebt riskant und atomstrom als
umweltfreundlich zu bezeichnen ist ein
hohn für jeden der durch die atom gaus
seine gesundheit seine heimat follower
und für jeden der unter den
hinterlassenschaften des uranbergbaus
leidet und afrika sei es in nordamerika
oder sei es in thüringen ronneburg oder
in westsachsen und für mich als
techniker ist die afg einfach nur wenn
sie auf eine technologie setzt die
transmutation heißt und nur in
computersimulationen funktioniert und
mein ganzer
1000 jahre rechtsstreit den produkten
die da übrig bleiben sind für die
menschheit immer noch unendlich lang
übrigens
wurde aus neuanlagen mit wind kostet 5
cent je kilowattstunde
sex und solaranlagen fast 20 cent ohne
versicherung atomstrom ja wir brauchen
eine sozialverträgliche energiewende und
deshalb fordert die linke die
stromsteuer abzuschaffen die eeg-kosten
aus dem steuermitteln zu bezahlen
wir fordern netzentgelte zu
vereinheitlichen
überflüssige industrie rabatten
abzuschaffen und jetzt für die fachleute
die scheiben pacht modelle zu verbieten
mit denen großkonzerne wie daimler und
bayer die ehrlichen strom kündigen und
stromkunden um 10 milliarden euro bei
der eeg-umlage betrogen haben vielen
dank
soweit ralph lenkert ich habe den
parlamentarischen beirat für nachhaltige
entwicklung schon erwähnt er allerdings
führen dieser legislaturperiode erst
noch zusammengesetzt werden muss in der
19 legislaturperiode war auch nina
scheer von der spd mitglied
[Applaus]
präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
ist es immer wieder erschüttern wie viel
stumpfsinn und falschbehauptungen aus
ihren reihen kommen und das ist ja der
anlass war auch bei uns halt hier mit
dem thema beschäftigen ich möchte zur
aufklärung nutzen und gleich mal
anfangen mit ein paar fakten die
dringend dem entgegengesetzt werden
müssen was ist darunter sie hier die
ganze zeit wieder unterstellen zum
beispiel die annahme dass weltweit
wieder eine renaissance der atomenergie
zu verzeichnen sei dass die
industrienationen alle auf eine in
atomenergie setzen in der tat es gibt
einige staaten die wie frankreich zum
beispiel jetzt sich ausgesprochen haben
noch mal eine milliarde ein
kernkraftwerk mehr sie haben aktuell 56
atomkraftwerke am netz und da muss man
auch mal sie die größenverhältnisse und
man muss auch erkennen dass die
industrienationen die eine abhängigkeit
zu atomwaffen haben das ist übrigens
auch eine antwort auf ihre fohlen
gestellte frage dass in der tat da in
die lamer entsteht weil sie natürlich in
der kostenfalle sitzen nach wie vor mit
dem know how im kontext atomwaffen
umgehen zu müssen und dann aber
gleichzeitig eigentlich erkennen müssen
dass die atomenergie
unwirtschaftlich ist aber sie in diesem
dilemma nummer städten wie sie das
bewerkstelligen müssen wenn sie nummer
atomwaffenstaaten sind das ist ein
dilemma dem wir uns auch an anderer
stelle widmen müssen
dann möchte ich noch mal unterstreichen
das ist ja auch viel von meinem
vorredner schon und auch aus den
fraktionen in der grünen gesagt worden
auch von timon gremmels unterstrichen
worden errichtet worden dargelegt worden
dass die atomenergie ein vielfaches
dessen kostet was erneuerbare energien
kosten sogar die atomenergie behörde
sieht das ja inzwischen nicht mehr
anders auch die atomenergiebehörde die
internationale energieagentur
erklärt dass sie nicht schätzt dass noch
im jahr 2030 mehr als 10% atomenergie im
anteil enthalten sein werden dann selbst
die größte interesse bündelung
organisation der welt dieses szenario
aufwirft wie um alles in der welt kann
man dann ernsthaft behaupten dass in der
atomenergie andere sorten renaissance
verankert sein dass dies zukunft hat und
damals auch diese frage ja das seien ja
alles die alten technologien es gäbe
eine neue generation da muss man auch
mal gründlich mit den fake news
aufräumen die meines erachtens in eine
eher die sich im sommer in die kategorie
corona leugnung man gleich mit der
kategorie corona andeutungen
gleichsetzen lassen weil man musste ich
jeden schwachsinn glauben die erzählt
wird und wenn einfach behauptet wird da
gibt es eine neue generation und selbst
in einem bill gates dahinter steckt muss
das nicht stimmen es gibt auch reiche
menschen auf der welt die nicht
unbedingt recht haben das ist diese
annahme dass
geld floss verzaubert der bringt ja
vielleicht auch ein ökonomisches
interesse durch verpflichtung strukturen
hat die die staaten ein gehen soll und
dann aufträge vermitteln das ist eben
übrigens ein sehr produktives leben fast
da drin steckt das muss doch nicht mit
für uns als politik bedeuten dass wir
die hinterher hüpfen das ist ein
gefährlicher weg den politik nicht
einschlagen darf nur weil irgendwo
reiche wäre auch der welt meinen da eine
geldanlage mit staatlicher hilfe
sichern zu können und da in diese
richtung gehen zu müssen diese mini
reaktoren diese mini reaktor und wollte
man zu 10.000 fachen um diese
energiemenge die dann auch nur zu
ersetzen wären oder die man jetzt noch
bräuchte um im kontext klimaneutralität
zu wirtschaften auszubauen wir bräuchten
zehntausende von den mini reaktoren
verteilt auf der ganzen welt wie bitte
schön soll ein sicherheitskonzept
aussehen wie bitteschön sollen
versicherungen aussehen die dies
bedeuten alleine dieser eine punkt sei
genannt es ist nicht leistbar sein
enormes sicherheitsrisiko und diese der
müll der angeblich dafür als rohstoff
herhalten soll 40 prozent des mülls ist
in glaskokillen verpackt 40 prozent
dieser müll kommt überhaupt nicht in
betracht das sind so viele unwahrheiten
die in ihren szenarien enthalten sind da
könnte ich noch weitere zehn minuten
mindestens darüber reden die zeit ist
leider zu ende ich danke für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
nina china war das und auch diese
debatte wird hierbei zu ende sein
andreas lenz spricht jetzt als letzter
redner
in der ersten debatte zunimmt drei
anträge fdp-fraktion er ist mitglied der
nation hier im deutschen bundestag
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ja wir haben
heute anträge der fw fraktion und vieles
ändert sich an diesen bundestag und in
dieser legislatur eines ändert sich aber
nicht berlin ihre anträge ab die anträge
sind wieder besonders neu noch besonders
originell und auch das sind wir ja
letztlich gewohnt es handelt sich um
eine ansammlung von irrtümern viele
informationen aber auch falsche
informationen und harrison ja genauso
was sie sagen sie haben vorhin gesagt
ihnen also dem rest des parlaments geht
es um die welt und wenn deutschland auf
der strecke bleibt ich habe jetzt einige
minuten nachgedacht über diesen satz von
ihnen und sie sollten sie sollten sich
diesen satz vielleicht auch noch mal
überlegen und auch noch mal darüber
nachdenken was aber wichtig ist ist die
frage der energieversorgung der zukunft
das thema atomstrom wird unterschiedlich
sehen unterschiedlich diskutiert auch
auf europäischer auf globaler ebene das
muss man ja auch ganz nüchtern
konstatieren aber zum einen wollen die
deutschen kraftwerksbetreiber diese
technologie im moment nicht und zum
anderen ist ja auch klar atomstrom ist
eben nicht die günstigste form der
energieerzeugung und übrigens gibt es
kein
versicherungsunternehmen auf der welt
dass atomkraftwerke versichert
marktwirtschaft sieht also anders aus
sehr geehrte damen und herren
unter der unionsgeführten
bundesregierung ging der ausbau der
erneuerbaren massiv fördern wir stehen
bei annähernd wir stehen bei annähernd
50 prozent erneuerbare im strombereich
wir haben das klimaschutzziel 2020 40
prozent weniger co2 ausstoß im vergleich
zu 1990
entsprechend als deutschland erreicht
wir haben den ressourcenverbrauch vom
wirtschaftswachstum entkoppelt und ja
das muss man schon sagen auch wenn es
nicht das waren wir und es waren eben
nicht sie wir haben die ziele erreicht
und wir haben die massiven zubau
entsprechenden der den letzten
legislaturen auch entsprechend
bewerkstelligt die union
die union hat eine nationale wasserstoff
strategie injiziert diese muss jetzt
weiter gedacht und entsprechend auf
nationaler und europäischer ebene
umgesetzt werden energiewende zu ende
gedacht wird nicht nur in deutschland
stattfinden wir brauchen internationale
kooperationen internationale
energiekooperation gerade wenn es um die
den bereich synthetische kraftstoffe
gerade auch wenn es dann um den bereich
der wasserstoffproduktion geht
deutschland hat im internationalen
vergleich mit die höchsten strom und
energiekosten dass es langfristig gift
für den produktionsstandort deutschland
und es ist im übrigen auch eine soziale
frage wir wollten beispielsweise in der
letzten legislatur bereits die
eeg-umlage abschaffen das war leider mit
dem damaligen finanzminister nicht
möglich und auch
und auch um die frage der
versorgungssicherheit müssen wir uns
zukünftig noch mehr bzw die zukünftige
regierung noch mehr kümmern es geht
natürlich um ersatzkapazitäten ist es ja
naiv zu glauben wenn man im ausland und
coole aussteigt würde man keine neuen
kapazitäten brauchen jetzt schreiben sie
zwar in ihrem sanierungspfad hier dass
die gaastra dass sie gas kraftwerke
errichten wollen aber die gaskraftwerke
die wachsen jetzt einfach nicht zu aus
dem boden sie brauchen andere als er sie
brauchen sie brauchen planungssicherheit
für investoren und diese kann es nur
durch einen kapazitäts markt die kann es
nur dadurch geben dazu künftig das
vorhalten von kapazitäten auch
entsprechend im system belohnt wird und
sie schreiben übrigens auf sie schauen
sie schreiben wir uns auch nicht mehr
diese gast wo er wie diese charta berge
betrieben werden sollen sie müssen ihr
verhältnis zur nord und zwar innerhalb
ihrer potentiellen ampel koalition erst
einmal klären meine damen und herren
obwohl wir obwohl wir bei der
energieversorgung natürlich auch die
europäische perspektive mit denken
müssen brauchen wir auch in deutschland
gesicherte leistung und das thema
versorgungssicherheit muss auch
entsprechend gesetzlich geregelt werden
liebe damen und herren und letzten endes
letzten endes brauchen wir zukünftig
auch weiterhin technologie wir brauchen
innovation wir brauchen anreize wir
brauchen natürlich auch einen massiven
ausbau der erneuerbaren aber eben auch
versorgungssicherheit und die
bezahlbarkeit und zum schluss in dem
sinne herzlichen dank für die
aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]